sprachlosigkeit bei olaf scholz im
kanzleramt gestern fassungslosigkeit
darüber und zwar international heute
bild am abend was war passiert
palästinenserpräsident abbas vergleicht
israel mit nazi-deutschland schlimmer
noch israel habe einen 50-fachen
holocaust an den palästinensern begangen
ein unerträglicher vergleich mit dem
mord an sechs millionen juden durch die
nazis und das sagte abbas im
bundeskanzleramt in der deutschen macht
zentral und der deutsche bundeskanzler
steht macht und kraftlos daneben und
sagt nichts und angeblich nur weil sein
pressesprecher die veranstaltung schon
für beendet erklärt hat der name heute
auch alle schuld auf sich scholz hätte
ihn gleich angeraunzt und er habe
grimmig geguckt beim anschließenden
handschlag mit aber viel kleiner kann
man sich als kanzler nicht machen lassen
achter dezember 2021 olaf scholz wird
kanzler ein verwalter ein arbeiter wird
zum regierungschef zum macher ernannt
vielleicht auch weil über seinen
konkurrenten nur gelacht wird seitdem
stellen sich viele märkte die frage ist
olaf scholz zu klein für das große amt
denn wer ein land führt wer auf der
bühne steht muss schnelle und richtige
entscheidungen treffen nicht so wie
jetzt beim besuch des
palästinenserpräsidenten
abbas der verharmlost den holocaust
vergleicht israel mit der nazi diktatur
und der kanzler steht daneben und
schweigt im denkbar schlechtesten moment
widerspricht der holocaust verharmlosung
nicht schlimmer noch es folgt ein
händeschütteln die pressekonferenz ist
beendet
erst auf bild nachfrage sagt stolz dass
jegliche holocaust relativierung
unerträglich und inakzeptabel sei zwölf
stunden brauchen dann olaf scholz und
seine mitarbeiter noch um sich bei
twitter empört über die unsäglichen
aussagen des palästinensischen
präsidenten zu zeigen für viele reicht
das nicht sie sagen der kanzler hätte
sofort reagieren müssen diese aussage
von kanzler scholz reicht nicht
deutschland hat führung bei olaf scholz
bestellt er hat führung versprochen
geliefert wird zögern und zaudern
beispiel krieg gegen die ukraine olaf
scholz schaffte es nach ausbruch des
krieges wochenlang nicht ein klares bild
abzugeben einen plan und eine haltung zu
waffenlieferungen zu präsentieren er
wirkt dünnhäutig und apathisch er wirkt
genervt vom krieg auch in der korona
krise verhält sich scholz so wie er es
schon immer getan hat abwarten zögern
sich hinter phrasen verstecken er
persönlich war für die impfpflicht
wollte sich aber als kanzler nicht dafür
einsetzen er kann kanzler nicht so
kritiker
überlastet
fragen der verantwortung die das
kanzleramt mit sich bringt wie ich recht
werden kann schon in hamburg war der
damalige erste bürgermeister scholz
bekannt für seine nicht antworten und
dafür dass er in unangenehmen
situationen ionen keine haltung zeigt
den g-20-gipfel bezeichnet er als
hafengeburtstag als hamburg brennt und
in gewalt und chaos versinkt sitzt stolz
in der elbphilharmonie typisch main
christoph ploß erkennt scholz aus seiner
zeit in hamburg und aktuell aus dem
bundestag
in die schuhe geschoben
nicht die verantwortung für sein
fehlverhalten gestern und das ist auch
etwas was wir aus hamburg kennen oder
scholz in wahlkämpfen immer davon
gesprochen dass er für und hat ja sogar
diesen spruch geprägt wehrführung
bestellt bekommt sie auch nach ende
haben wir genau das gegenteil bekommen
und das gleiche gilt nun auch unser land
wie führung und durchsetzungsvermögen
gehen zeigen robert habeck
wirtschaftsminister und annalena
baerbock aus ministerin und damit liegen
sie in der wählergunst weit vor kanzler
scholz annalena baerbock liefert sich
mit ihrem türkischen amtskollegen auf
offener bühne einen schlagabtausch auch
bei ihrem besuch in der ukraine weit vor
stolz wirbt sie ehrlich bewegt und klar
in ihrer haltung
robert habeck managt derzeit die gas und
energiekrise verhandelt mit neuen
lieferanten und wird die bevölkerung auf
einen harten winter ein
deshalb fragen sich derzeit viele wäre
habeck der bessere kanzler
die frage gleich weiter an bild tv
chefredakteur claus strunz wäre habeck
der bessere gute frage also wenn man im
moment politische situation anschaut
wäre er wahrscheinlich auch der kanzler
denn wenn ich es richtig sehe haben die
grünen die besseren umfrageergebnisse
als die spd und ganz unstreitig ist es
so dass
arabic er auf der höhe des moment ist
frau baerbock ganz stark in
ungewöhnlichen momenten spontan
reagiert und zeigt wo sie steht auf der
richtigen seite und ganz klar ist seit
den ereignissen im kanzleramt dass olaf
scholz nicht auf der höhe des moments
ist er ist ein meister des vorbereitet
science ein meister des akten lesens ein
genie des aktenvermerks aber er ist ganz
offensichtlich dann wenn es aufs
momentum ankommt nicht auf der höhe und
deshalb dreht die frage in den
vordergrund über das format für dieses
hohe amt in deutschland hat das ist ja
der entscheidende punkt ein kanzler muss
in entscheidenden momenten auch intuitiv
handeln können muss die richtige
entscheidung treffen gerade in diesen
krisenzeiten wir müssen uns auch darauf
verlassen können als bürger können wir
uns darauf verlassen nach dem
totalausfall gestern immer noch bei olaf
scholz also zweifel sind berechtigt nach
diesem wirklichen totalausfall und auch
nach den beispielen die wir jetzt eben
mir angeguckt haben immer dann wenn er
als nummer eins in eine situation gerät
die nicht vorhersehbar war bleibt der
die souveränität und die richtige
handlung schuldig und wenn man sich
überlegt in welcher situation einen
kanzler also derjenige der unsere
interessen vertritt auch in
internationalen verhandlungen kommen
kann in einer nacht verhandlung mit
erdogan und
anderen starken verhandlern dann stellt
sich dann die frage ob scholz dafür das
richtige navigationssystem hat oder ob
er immer sein muss da muss ich erstmal
meine pressesprecher fragen ob ich jetzt
noch reden darf das ist ja der
eigentliche
fast schmerzhafter skandal im skandal
was wir da gesehen haben das ist jetzt
heißt der pressesprecher hat entschieden
das jetzt zu ende ist und dann kann auch
der kanzler nichts mehr sagen zu haben
aber sowas dämlich ist habe ich noch nie
gehört und es ist eigentlich einer
führung eines landes nicht würdig
bemerkenswert war dass selbst die
ehemalige kanzlerin angela merkel sich
genötigt fühlte sich zu wort zu melden
die ja sonst ihre nachfolgeregierung gar
nicht kommentiert sagte das sei
unerträglich und sowas würde in
deutschland nicht geduldet und nun es
wurde aber geduldet jetzt haben die
bürger ja immer das gefühl gehabt so
eine frau wie angela merkel hatte in
krisenzeiten eigentlich eine ruhige an
da konnte man sich darauf verlassen olaf
scholz probiert ist ja auch mit dieser
ruhigen hand warum kommt es bei ihnen
nicht so rüber na ja sie hatte die
besseren ausgangssituationen weil sie
immer mit einer größeren mehrheit im
rücken also mächtiger in einer koalition
reagierte regiert hat ich glaube aber
auch dass es einen großen unterscheidung
punkt gibt er in dieser woche für olaf
schulze einschlägig ist olaf scholz
gedanken sind auch möglicherweise nicht
immer nur bei dem was er gerade tut
sondern bei dem was in der vergangenheit
war bei comics einem skandal indessen
schlund er noch verschwinden kann neuer
tricks weiter steuertricks reihen in
seiner hamburger zeit wo und er
sicherlich seine altlasten mit sich
herumträgt und ich glaube das ist einer
der unterschiede angela merkel hat viele
stärken auch viele schwächen hat ist zu
recht kritisiert worden für ihre an
mancher stelle falsche politik aber sie
war immer in dem moment dort wo die
musik spielte und nicht mit ihren
gedanken in einem skandalen in dem sie
früher verwickelt war das gab es bei ihr
nicht das machte sie souveräner und wie
man hört und weiß zu einer virtuosen des
moments eine frau die den moment immer
nutzen konnte für ihre position ob das
dann immer die position war die für
deutschland die allerbeste war es was
anderes aber darum geht es ja und das
bleibt olaf scholz schuldig das ist fast
so wie ein mittelstürmer der sich schön
die schnürsenkel zu machen kann im
trikot toll aussieht aber leider den
ball ins tor bringt
[Musik]